uh i had a it was funny i ran to bill
birth airport probably
11 years ago and we sat down and we were
talking about the same thing we're
talking about right now like
uh you know frustration with the
business bill goes you know what i'm
just gonna be so
[__] funny they can't deny
he's saying because the only thing he
can really control is how funny you are
because he's going to be so funny they
can't deny me
i was like yeah it makes less sense yeah
and that that is something like we're
talking about
comedians can do it themselves now and
you self-produced three specials
showtime picked up your newest one but
you were always like that diy approach
but that hustle of getting funny first
like you driving four hours for five
minutes and sleeping in your car
and that's like the grind part that i
feel like comedians see
oh i can just do it myself but you have
to get funny first
you know like one one before the other
type deal
well we're in a you know it's a
different grind nowadays like i i had um
i had dizzy banks on my podcast yeah
i've had them on here yeah yeah
we were talking about it and i said you
know the grind's different now now the
grind
is you know get up get your phone out
and let's get with your friends and come
up with a sketch
which is a grind in itself you can just
sit around tv
you know what i mean and then to edit it
and put it out there
and you know you're seeing a lot of
these young guys with quality
like programmed it looks like uh it
looks like they had a
four-camera shoot and they're on their
phone editing it
so i mean the grind is just a little
different it's still it's still a grind
but it's just it's it's changing and we
have to change with it you know back in
back in when i started we were at the
mercy of networks
and tv execs we couldn't just get our
material out there
it just wasn't possible there wasn't any
outlets nowadays you're not
you're not at the mercy look at look at
andrew schultz
i said i i text him all the time and i
go dude you like
you really inspire me by
what you're doing i said it's a matter
of time for the network to come after
him
and they're either gonna have to pay top
dollar to get him because he's he's like
he built his own studio yeah he's got
his own little talk show now
i know it's incredible so what it what
are you doing i know you have your
podcast
uh what else are you self-producing or
what are opportunities are you seeing
you're trying to take advantage of and
that comics in general can start to take
advantage of
well i mean right off the bat get as
much stuff out on youtube as you can
and see what sticks to the wall because
you know
youtube is they're paying now they got
you can get monetized you get a thousand
subscribers and
however many views you can start i mean
i'll be honest
that's why i did those lockdown videos
during the pandemic
i got on every day and just did a four
or five minute rant about
something because one of
it kept me sane kept my brain like
working
but two on youtube i was monetized
so it's it's money it's revenue coming
in when
we're not on the road you know mm-hmm
are there are there any other ways we
can monetize our comedy
um if you get a something catchy i guess
you could do an online store
there's t-shirts we got masks now i mean
i talked to duval
he he got that t-shirt out there um what
do you say
uh we're in this together but stay the
[__] away from me and what his t-shirt
said
uh he said they can i don't want to put
his mind out there but he's right he was
making a decent amount of money off
of just that t-shirt and that wasn't on
a comedy special
he just like put it out there on the
internet and people gravitated
to it you know so there i mean there's
there's ways
there's outlets thanks for watching hot
breath the verse if you want to support
the show
go join our patreon but if you don't
like supporting a comic on the hustle
at least click the watch more videos to
keep us alive
in the algorithm